so church is digital you know life is
digital our careers digital increasingly
digital increasingly you're gonna see
last 14 days you know no question about
it I think you're gonna see a major
shift I think I think you're gonna see
it real change in education higher
education it's gonna be very interesting
to see I think anybody who makes a bunch
of predictions right now I wouldn't put
a whole lot of stock in it because so
much is changing but I do think there
you're going to see some companies who
were not open to remote working they'll
say you know what we're okay with it in
certain instances you're gonna see some
of that you're gonna see again education
change forever I think public school
systems are a lot of them are caught you
know they got caught and and it's like
what do we do here and we're seeing a
higher education that's gonna change the
type of things that people are doing I
saw an article today that again I think
is worth considering so I won't cite it
I don't think it's it's the truth but I
think it's something to consider is that
you're gonna see a lot of kids Dave
right now that are juniors and seniors
in high school and because of this
change in the economy
something we're gonna go you know what
I've watched what's happened to mom and
dad over the last three four months I
might go right into a trade because the
trades are an industry that are going to
exploit her so we're doing quite well
right central they're all work they're
very essential and I think that's a and
again I think the article is
well-written there's an interesting
piece of critical thought there there is
bottom line is is that market disruption
does one of two things
you're either ride the wave of it you
create the wave one of three things
let's make the wave you ride the wave er
you're destroyed by the wave and I
always think of the story of Frederic
Tudor and 1820 took the first load of
ice in the hull of a ship from
Newfoundland to Martinique because
people needed ice and their drinks he
decided got there with very little of
the ice because he didn't even have
insulation right and then he invented
installed insulation but the point was
made and point was made and asked
forward from 1820 a hundred years later
the ice business was still pretty much
operating that way blocks of ice with
big tongs being delivered by wagons or
ice
trucks to your front door your great
grandparents or great-grandparents had
an icebox which was a little more than a
glorified cooler that's right and they
put a chunk a big square chunk of ice in
the bottom of it until the market was
disrupted by this thing called freon
invented by an offshoot of General
Motors a subsidiary of General Motors a
company called Frigidaire invented freon
and a commercial refrigeration without
ice was born and you would think the ice
business was gone but there was an ice
company down in Texas that saw that
coming they delivered ice but they also
had at the ice house because it was cold
they kept meat and eggs and milk and
people would come by on off-hours odd
hours the grocery stores weren't open
and pick up the meat and the eggs and
the milk it was a convenience item and
so as the ice business went away because
of refrigeration the convenience
business didn't go away and that ice
company down in Texas had these weird
hours it was open from 7 to 11
convenience store 7 to 11 I did not know
that
that's where 7-eleven came from a guy
named Jimmy Graham started that you may
say Jimmy Graham just completely flipped
to wit with the disruption what and
guess what a whole bunch of ice houses
just went out of business mm-hmm but
instead of that instead he said well
this is what we were doing let's and by
the way we sold a billion dollars in ice
last year for picnics so the ice
business didn't go away it just changed
and your business didn't go away she
changed her career if your dream didn't
go away it just changed you either cause
the wave of disruption which in this
case and no one caused it
at least we don't think a person caused
this obviously we hope no one caused it
the no one causes so you either cause
disruption you ride the wave of
disruption or you're crushed by the wave
of disruption and sometimes that's just
your posture it really is and I think
you make a great point here what are we
going to do we being all of us we've
been disrupted there's no one that's
immune from this disruption and I think
you make a VAT word I know I can't help
myself but you know it's a situation
where you have to decide am I going to
rise again if I've gotten completely
knocked off the horse am I gonna get
back up and again Dave you mentioned
this last week when I was on with you
here's what we know 70% of Americans 80%
worldwide were unhappy in their jobs
prior to this and yet we were at
historic unemployment numbers low in
employment numbers in the United States
so in some ways this is the opportunity
to begin again and and I think that
that's what's exciting about this to see
what industries will develop I posted
something on social media on my
Instagram page about all the different
companies that came out of the last
recession so you think of the big
recession what year was that day what
2007-2008 just to give you an idea you
bir didn't exist
Airbnb didn't exist slack Pinterest
whatsapp Square venmo Groupon and the
list could go on and on and on but these
are examples of things that are now one
name you say it around the world we know
what it means in fact it's like remember
when Kleenex became a thing and it was
just a brand name it was hand me a
Kleenex well that was the brand name now
people say I'm going to Ober over to you
so when there is a disruption there is
an opportunity for invention and
reinventing ourselves as leaders
reinforce a lot of those things were not
necessarily born because of the
recession no they were born in spite
that's right of the recession at the
recession that's thousand eight that's
right so I mean I don't I don't hear one
of those that says oh the recession gave
them a leg up no you know I mean squares
is a payment system right
you know you plug it just the technology
came of age that's right okay so the
payment processors came of age it's
right and and they're probably about the
same thing happened with uber honestly
yeah and so you know some of these
things come of age so what's coming of
age yeah about the time everything got
turned on its head here and I gotta tell
you if I'm in the brick-and-mortar
retail business I better figure out
what's my version of Amazon that's one
thing for my version or something better
get your online distribution figured out
I can tell you at Ramsey we've been
and figuring out a way to get you guys
delivered stuff right that's right and
it has changed the shape of this company
because we've been trying to serve you
right now and we probably are going to
keep some of that the rest of our lives
it were reshaped automatically it's it's
both terrifying and exciting that's
right